[Music]
[Applause]
fireworks is a new film that's being
released across the nation and a limited
capacity there was one tonight and
there's a few over the next few days I
think that dubbed showing is on the
seventh the one I saw tonight was the
subtitled version and this film is about
a bunch of schoolchildren who are trying
to figure out if fireworks look round or
flat when they explode in the air one of
these young boys is named Nura Michi and
he has a crush on a girl named nazuna
who just so happens to find a
transparent ball that has some control
over time and we embark on a love
triangle movie filled with angst that
also has a bit of a time travel element
and the marketing around here has told
us that it's from the producer of your
name which I thought was fantastic one
of the best anime films I've ever seen
and so naturally that's pretty much why
I went to the theater I was like okay
well let's see what else this guy's got
going on so over the years I've gotten a
very specific request and that is to
review an anime that actually isn't good
because normally I review anime I like I
usually don't try to waste my time in a
theater or buying an expensive blu-ray
or getting a subscription to some online
content that allows me to watch
something if I don't think it's going to
be good but I went to the theater
tonight and I saw fireworks and holy
it's legitimately one of the worst
anime movies I have ever laid eyes on
now it's not as bad as something like
gars e's wing don't get me wrong it's
not that level of atrocious it's not
early 90s English dub atrocious I never
said I was the holy warrior if you had a
convenience store then I would live with
you what is that but I know there are no
vending machines here either but from a
storytelling standpoint I found myself
constantly reminded of the anime FLCL or
fooly cooly which is one of my favorites
but specifically the very bizarre and
off-kilter sense that that anime has
that they are trying to achieve it's
purposeful in that anime in this film
it's achieved because it's just so bad
that I began to feel like I was in a
trance
because I was in awe at everything that
I was seeing this is a very very very
disappointing anime film that had a lot
of potential going in from the animation
studio shaft but the story is so
bare-bones and lacking of any real
inspiration or character choices that
make sense
that I just couldn't get into it but for
the first 30 minutes of a film that ends
up being about 90 minutes long
really nothing happens it's just some
kids arguing about the bust size of one
of their teachers and then trying to
figure out if when a firework explodes
it's round or flat when viewed at from
different angles which is throughout
this entire film this argument they have
and it never comes to a head this
argument never has an arc it's just this
really pointless conversation that eats
up so much of the runtime okay but at
the core of a film like this what you
really want to work is the romance this
boy who's lusting after this girl who
feels very lonely and needs protection
which is a classic anime trope where the
female character just doesn't really
have anything to her except she's like
this mystical perfect woman that needs
help or protection and is everything
that this boy could ever want but beyond
that she has no real personality yeah
that's her character and every single
choice that these characters make just
doesn't make sense once the boy realizes
he's reversing time with this
transparent ball you don't even really
get the sense that he understands what's
going on and so much later you never get
any private moments with him where he's
thinking about what's happening like in
your name for instance when these
characters realize they're switching
bodies they have all these amazing
moments to themselves where they realize
what's going on and you can understand
what the characters are feeling this
film just kind of expects that if it's
pretty enough and romantic enough that
somehow will appreciate this story
despite the fact that it has barely any
emotion to it I know nothing about the
lead character in this movie I know
barely anything about the girl either
most of the film is just them arguing
about the bust size of one of their
teachers look this is
something that happens a lot in anime
but there are so many moments like that
in this film that have nothing to do
with the story and it's not funny and I
just feel like we're past that you know
it's hard to really describe just how
inept the character development is
beyond saying that there really isn't
any and the things that they're saying
it just doesn't flow like a natural
conversation I'm not sure if it's
because it was a bad subtitle
translation but I doubt that because
this is G kids I believe and and they're
pretty on top of things I've always
loved G kids and I still do but when it
comes to this film the things the
characters say the conversations they
have it just doesn't flow as if people
are speaking and it's not just because
they're young and we're supposed to
accept that their angst E and they're
nervous it's because the dialogue is
written so poorly I can barely
understand what's happening half the
time the time-travel elements of the
film feels unnecessary and kind of
confusing to be honest the ending of the
film also feels very out of left field
and it's almost more pretentious than
this film deserves like it's really
trying to say something with its ending
and in the long run
it just doesn't earn any of these
emotions because I did not give one
single about any of the characters
and the choices they made were so stupid
and didn't make any sense that I gotta
be honest this is probably one of the
worst anime films I've seen that got a
theatrical release in America when I
watch an anime film there's something I
like to do I like to think what if
someone was sitting next to me like a
friend of mine who isn't into anime
who's watching this with me what would
they be thinking would this play for
them would they get this or would they
just be scratching their head and I was
picturing a friend of mine sitting next
to me while watching fireworks or as the
official title is called fireworks
should we see it from the side or the
bottom which I just can't bring myself
to say in this review I'm just going to
ignore that I'm picturing my friends
staying next to me and there are so many
scenes in this film where he would just
be losing his mind and laughing his ass
off
there's supernatural like voids that
they enter where they're on like a
horse-drawn carriage and she just starts
singing it
things happen that don't make sense and
this is coming from a massive
anime fan I've seen a lot of weird
okay not saying I've seen some fucked-up
the romance in it rang completely
Hollow the characters made choices so
stupid that I couldn't really comprehend
what they were doing or what they were
saying even sometimes and they were so
unlikable as people that I just couldn't
bring myself to enjoy watching them do
anything let's talk for a brief moment
about the animation sometimes the
backgrounds are very nice sometimes
there's an over-reliance on
computer-generated animation this is a
really disappointing anime that could
have been so much better I'm gonna give
fireworks
a d-plus it's possible that some viewers
might find a hidden meaning here or
something to connect with that I just
didn't but I'm seeing this as more of an
anime fan party movie where everyone
laughs and drinks whenever something
insane happens so I don't know go see it
maybe if you want to have a laugh or you
just want to see some really weird
that doesn't quite make sense or a ton
of boob jokes because apparently it's
1995 and boob jokes are just like in oh
my god I forgot to talk about the guy
who says when he sees hot chicks he
wants to poop I forgot to talk about
that I'm just gonna leave it there guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you